- 2020 Is finally coming to a close.
So, we're looking back
on the year's best shows,
on this week's Binge Guide.
If there is one silver lining
to the garbage fire of a year,
that was 2020, it was the
incredible slate of TV
and streaming shows that occupied
our couch-filled days at home,
and while there were
plenty of contenders for
the best of the year,
we think this list will leave you
happily bingeing well into 2021.
So, in no particular order here
are our best shows of 2020.
Starting with "The Queen's Gambit"
This chest centric limited series
was a smash hit for Netflix,
and features in addictive story,
captivating dialogue,
and stylish art direction that
make for a compelling watch
from start to finish that's
really hard not to binge.
With a 99% Tomatometer score,
critics and audiences praise the show
for star Anya Taylor Joy's
magnetic performance,
and calling the show an absolute win.
Bingeing the whole series
takes just seven hours,
which is honestly nothing
compared to the time
that you'll spend playing
chess, after watching it.
Next on our list is the FX series,
"What We Do In The Shadows"
Based on the 2014 film of the same name,
this horror mockumentary
from Taika Waititi and Jemaine Clement,
follows a group of vampires
living together in Staten Island,
which is way more
hilarious than it sounds.
The second season builds on
the good will from the first,
and has been given unanimous praise,
with 10 Emmy nominations,
and a 100% on the Tomatometer,
with critics saying it "savvily expands
its supernatural horizons,
while doubling down on the fast flying fun."
With 20 episodes total,
you can binge both
seasons in about 10 hours,
which is like a blink of an eye
when you live forever like a vampire.
Another 2020 breakout worth bingeing is
"I May Destroy you"
Co-produced by HBO and BBC,
this comedy drama explores sexual assault
and modern dating using a blend
of carefully crafted storylines
and ultra believable characters
that infuse humanity and a surprising
amount of levity into an
otherwise dark subject.
Star Michaela Coel's undeniable talent
is on full display in front
and behind the camera,
as she co-directed eight
episodes in the first season,
which critics called "brave and delicate"
in its ability to balance dark humor,
with moments of deep discomfort.
And at an easy half hour each,
you can binge all 12 episodes
of the series in just around six hours.
Next up is another one of
our returning favorites,
"The Boys"
After a killer first season,
Amazon's atypical superhero
series returned in 2020
with more irreverent action,
jaw-dropping violence,
and timely societal commentary
as our ragtag group of
heroes continued their fight,
against the corporate created supes.
Critics called the second season "superb",
praising the show's ability
to "up the action ante
without pulling socially critical punches."
You can watch the entire
series in about 16 hours,
and if you can get through
it all in one sitting,
then you can call
bingeing your superpower.
And rounding out our list
is one of the funniest
shows ever, "Schitt's Creek"
This comedy series created
by and starring Dan and Eugene Levy
about a wealthy family who's
forced to move to a town
that they purchased as a joke
made history when it's
six and final season
swept the comedy categories
at the Emmy's a first for any genre.
And with a Certified Fresh
Tomatometer score of a 100%,
critics called the final season,
"witty, warm, and a fitting farewell."
You can binge all six seasons
of Schitt's in 28 hours,
and then you'll have nothing
but hilarious one-liners,
and Moira's accent stuck in your head.
EW, DAVID!
All right friends, hopefully this list
will keep you bingeing
well into the new year.
Did your favorite make our list?
Let us know in the comments.
And be sure to check out
the new Rotten Tomatoes Is Wrong
a Podcast from Rotten Tomatoes,
because Fresh and Rotten
is just the beginning of the conversation,
and new episodes drop every Thursday,
We hope to see you guys back here
for more recommendations
based around the movies,
and shows that you love right here
on the Rotten Tomatoes Binge Guide.
(upbeat music)